but right now we do have breaking news
from Ukraine Russia has launched drone
and missile attacks on multiple cities
across the country this occurring
overnight causing rolling blackouts in
several regions at least one person was
killed in the capital city of Kiev
though Ukraine claims it did shoot down
most of the incoming this was keyword
most it may be Russia's response to the
U.S and allies promising to provide
Western tanks to Ukraine's military
after months of hesitation on that point
for more on all of it let's go to Ed
O'Keefe at the White House Ed Good
morning Tony good morning to you the U.S
and European allies are pledging
Advanced tanks and equipment to help
Pierce through that Russian offensive
the question at this point is how
quickly can the tanks be delivered and
how quickly can Ukrainian forces be
trained to use them
tank battles along the Eastern front of
the Ukrainian War are already part of
the ongoing Siege
and now American plans to supply some of
the world's most powerful tanks have
opened the door for European allies to
also Supply heavy arms these tanks are
further evidence of our enduring
unflagging commitment to Ukraine the U.S
is sending 31 M1 Abrams Tanks enough for
a Ukrainian tank Battalion they'll be
joined by Germany which is sending
Advanced Leopard 2 tanks that allows
Poland and other European countries to
pledge similar equipment armored
vehicles are are important you know you
uh you know go after a crocodile with a
corn stock and and these in these
vehicles these tanks those armored
vehicles they're they're going to have
they're going to have an effect CBS News
National Security analyst H.R McMaster
says the tanks will give Ukraine much
needed Firepower against the Russian if
the crew knows what it's doing is well
trained does the prep the fire checks
maintains that tank well you just can't
miss and everything you hit is
catastrophically destroyed in Congress
where support for Ukraine remained
strong many lawmakers wonder what took
so long it's really an admission of
their own mistakes not providing these
tanks months ago While others warned
this is just the start the West's work
is far from over
in public Wednesday Russian President
Vladimir Putin made no mention of the
tank announcement but Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski celebrating
his 45th birthday did
thanking every American family for the
Global Leadership and calling to form a
fist of Tanks a fist for freedom
part of why this is getting so much
attention is that even three months ago
nobody anticipated that the U.S or
European allies would be sending tanks
to the Ukrainian front lines it's a
reminder Gail that this conflict is just
nowhere near over I know Ed and I'll bet
nobody thought it would last as long as
it's lasting but here we are thank you
very much